I wanted what did what I wanted to talk
to you guys about today was a little bit
about what we do at planet labs and why
and a little bit of some of the lessons
I've learned on this entrepreneurial
journey if you like for others that are
interested in taking similar journeys I
hope it will be useful but much of it
will be for my personal perspective so
take it with a that grain of salt I want
to start us here this is called the
earth you may have seen it before you
may have seen it before in particular
because of this rather iconic image that
the Apollo 17 astronauts took when they
were hurtling around the moon in 1972
the first full-frame image of the entire
planet win it was fully sunlit and it's
credited with having started the green
movement not so much because we didn't
know we were living on a planet before
then or at least most people thought we
did it is the case though that it hadn't
really gone into the public
consciousness and this changed a lot of
people's thinking this particular
photograph because they saw the thin
shell of the atmosphere they thought saw
the earth in the vastness of space and
make people realize that we've got to
take care of this beautiful planet that
we're on but beautiful as this picture
is it's a little bit lacking it's
lacking because it's static and the
earth is constantly changing as we in
particular effect the planet as human
beings and and what one would eat
ideally like is much more high cadence
imagery high frequency imagery of the
planet so satellite imagery today is
typically older that the image you find
online is typically several years old
and so we did a thought experiment what
would it be like if we could take a
high-resolution image of every single
point on the Earth's surface every
single day what could we do with that
data we were thinking well we could
track deforestation we could see that as
it happens rather than waking up at the
end of the year and realizing there's a
bloody great hole in the Amazon again we
could catch people in the act right as
the logging takes place over many
we could do the same for fisheries we
could see disasters like the situation
happening in a pool right now and help
people quickly get the imagery they need
to figure out how to respond to those
situations same with floods fires
earthquakes well that is an earthquake
other other disasters as well we'd also
be able to help people improve
agricultural yield because with
satellite data you can tell biomass in
every single pixel and so we could help
people improve agriculture around the
world and then there are a lot of
commercial applications for example
having up-to-date imagery is something
that people want on their consumer
mapping products and so everyone wants
that on their phone instead of an image
several years old they want the image
from recently and there's lots of
financial applications as well and so me
and my co-founders who are at NASA at
the time left NASA to start a company to
try and tackle that problem of trying to
get to daily imaging of the planet and
so that was the mission we set out image
the whole earth every single day and
provide universal access to that imagery
and so roughly what does that take it
takes a system like this we need about
150 satellites orbiting the Earth in a
particular orbit we need a system of 30
ground stations around the world to
receive the information down from those
satellites we need of course large
numbers of processes in order to to
digest and make that information
calibrated and gia rectified onto the
Earth's surface so it's useful for
consumers and then we thought about two
ways of sort of provisioning that out to
customers one via sort of feed hoses to
large enterprise users say those
consumer mapping clients that I was
talking about but also we wanted to get
it out on a platform so that everyone
could have access to it so we have an
open API where anyone can come and hack
their own apps on our imagery on our
servers so that's roughly what we set
out to do and this little video is going
to show you how it would work so we put
150 satellites into a sun-synchronous
plane that they're all in the same plane
and they actually stay fixed that plane
stays fixed with respect to the Sun
the Earth rotates underneath it each one
is pointing down and taking a strip of
imagery along the ground and then by the
time the next one comes along the earth
is rotated just the width of the image
so that it it stripes the part just next
to it it ends up being like a line
scanner for the planet so we basically
the earth does the legwork and we just
stay put and let the earth rotate
underneath it and slowly scanner a line
scanner for the planet this is two of
our satellites being deployed from the
International Space Station it gives you
a bit of a sense of scale of how small
our satellites are versus the solar
arrays of the space station and what I'm
going to tell you a little bit is about
is that about what it took to get there
and some of the the journey first so we
started this in our garage as Silicon
Valley startups I want to do but I think
we were the first space startup to do
that we literally built up a satellite
in our garage and that wasn't the only
lesson we learnt from Silicon Valley we
took an approach of a rapid iteration we
call agile aerospace and I'll tell you a
little bit more about that in a minute
we try to just take things out into the
field and test them we would take our
satellites out we fire them in planes
over our ground stations to check that
work have have have the radio tests
along across the valley from here to
basically the Lick Observatory would
send somebody up there and try and do a
link and make sure everything worked so
we took this sort of more hands-on and
testing approach which is quite
different from the aerospace sector
which takes a very hardcore analytical
approach to finding problems and risks
to the satellite design so we started in
our garage and that was just over three
years ago three and a half years ago and
we actually the founders of our company
we all met at the United Nations a
conference that was looking at how to
use satellites to help humanity how can
we bring them to help people in
developing countries help stop disasters
things like that and so this in many
ways has been the uniting theme
throughout our careers we've known each
other for about 15 years before starting
this company and
we were longtime friends and cared about
this overarching mission so what was
standing in our way the first thing that
was standing in our way was that
satellites looked like this you see
these people they're rather big the
satellites either that other people are
very small so these satellites way about
six tons that this is a Landsat
satellite it was launched last year by
NASA this is what a traditional earth
imaging satellite looks like so weighs
six tons is 4 x 4 x 6 meters it costs
855 million dollars it was launched on a
single rocket and satellites like this
have done a tremendous service in
helping us to understand the planet so
far this is this sort of seller has
given us reliable data over the last 40
years but if you want to put up 150
satellites this model doesn't really
work because well at least not unless
you have a gigantic budget but that
doesn't really represent the forefront
of satellite technology at least small
satellite technology which really was
represented prior to us at least by
these folks at sorry satellites who
actually from the UK and these are some
of their satellites that they build a
rapid eye is the constellation of
satellites that they built here shown
and these sellers are about a hundred
kilograms and a commensurately less
money only say 30 million or 40 million
dollars but even that for us was not
going to work we needed to put up 150 of
these guys and even by that standards it
was going to be billions of dollars and
not something we could get venture
capital funded let alone try and start
out of our own pockets which is what we
wanted to do so what we did was make
satellites much smaller and this is
actually one of our satellites under
construction by one of our engineers to
give you a bit of a sense of scale so I
satellites this is actually one of them
what it looks like one of the dominant
features you can see is actually are we
have an artist in residence who paints
all of our satellites and this is
actually the top side of the solar array
so you can't see the main solar array
obviously that has to
the solar cells on it but the artist
gets to to paint the other parts which
is kind of cool but what's inside that
so we've miniaturized a massive amount
of technology into this little volume
these satellites are 10 x 10 x 30
centimeters they use what's called the
CubeSat form factor which actually
Stanford engineers were involved with
with pioneering in the late 90s it's
basically a standard form factor of size
of a satellite and launch providers got
used to this form factor to give more
which enabled us to get more access to
space basically but inside there is Miss
and foremost the largest telescope we
could possibly fit into that volume so
you know to the front two thirds of the
satellite is essentially the telescope
which is the optics that you need to get
reasonable resolution imagery of the
ground from four or five hundred
kilometers up which is where we're
orbiting then we have a camera system at
the back which that telescope fees to
and on our latest generation is a 29
megapixel camera but in addition to that
that's only really just the beginning
and what one has to have is obviously
the power systems to the batteries and
the solar power to keep them charged we
have to have an attitude determination
system so that's the system that figures
out where the satellite is and where
it's pointing so we have a gps antenna
that picks up that and actually gps
works in space you might question
whether it would or not but it does with
that much lower than the GPS satellites
so it still works and we have a star
camera which looks out up whilst the
main camera is looking down and takes
pictures of the star field and then
automatically recognize these
constellations and then add metadata to
our main image to say you have pointed
this way when you took that image so we
have a timestamp the GPS stamp says
where it's at in the orbit and then this
star camera stamp if you like says which
way are we pointing at the time there's
a lot of other sensors in here there's a
three axis accelerometer 3 x's rate gyro
3 x's magnet
no matter these will feed into a common
filter to spit out the satellite
position and attitude state then we have
a system of attitude control so that's
what then said well we now know where
we're pointing now we need to point
somewhere else with the ground safe
we're pointing up or what have you and
so we have two systems of attitude
control one is a system of reaction
wheels so these are little brushless DC
motors essentially that were put in in
in in all three axes and if you spin
them one way then the settle has to spin
the other way to conserve momentum and
so we can turn the satellite round just
by turning on these motors we have an
independent other system of attitude
control which is using magnetic coils so
these are little little just literally
while a system of copper wire that
we put through a little current which
creates a little B field which reacts
against the Earth's really small
magnetic field and gives just enough
talk to turn our satellites around as
well so we have two independent means of
turning our satellites around one is
completely simple that that magnet auger
call and very robust but it's a little
bit slower and so when we're turning for
example to point our ground station to
maximize the gain of our radio antenna
we use our reaction wheels but for most
the time we can use our magnet auger
good also in there we have a process
that we actually three processes we have
an FPGA which does the initial
compression of the imagery we have a
full up x86 process of running ubuntu
and then we've also got an ARM processor
that does a lot of the light work
scheduling of the of the satellite
operations and so actually despite being
some of the smaller satellites ever they
are some of the most capable satellites
ever in terms of the compute power on
board we've got more memory and
processing power than a lot of other
satellites if not all of them just
because we use the latest technology and
stuff it in and we take slightly higher
risk approach which I'll be talking more
about then we have a radio systems to
send down the data so we have three
radios on board
all of which we developed in-house
because the cheapest radio we could find
that would do the job was larger than
our satellite and cost about a million
dollars so it was out of scope on two
axes axes so we build our own radio in
house that we have it has a three
channels UHF channel which does the
command and control of the satellite an
S band which is where we send the data
up and an x-band which is eight point
three gigahertz to send the data down
and we can send out data down about 40
megabits a second down to our ground
stations that around the world and I'll
show you a little bit what the ground
stations look like in a minute as well
so that's what the satellite looks like
and as I mentioned we take this sort of
agile approach and what I mean by that
is we constantly put in the latest
technology so in between the last two
that one we just launched about a month
ago today where we lost 14 satellites
and we always put a tech demo satellite
on testing our next-generation
technology and then we put a fleet of
ones that we know of work right and then
if that one works then we'll just
produce loads of those for the next
batch so the tech demo one that we had
on this one for example had double the
field of view on the telescope we had we
gone up 3x in the number of pixels on
the camera we had doubled the hard drive
space on that satellite we'd increase
the radio speed we have put new sensors
in helped us to do better attitude
control Sun sensors basically and so we
keep on iterating the technology we call
this strapping space to Moore's law you
know basically trying to leverage the
billions of dollars that have gone into
consumer electronics and stuff them into
our satellites and although that seems
pretty obvious that's not really what
the space industry has been doing a till
now and it might be obvious to you and I
but it's not what's been going on so
basically there's traditionally you can
only put something into space if it is
already been tested in space which this
sort of chicken in an egg then
everything is antiquated and there's
very long design life cycles for these
things so they want the last long time
so they want reliable technology and
they designed them over many many
us so what ends up happening is you end
up launching antiquated technology and
so the processors on the latest mission
on Mars as a 33 megahertz processor and
a 2-megapixel camera because 20 years
ago that was really hot but but
unfortunately yeah I mean you can't even
find a 33 megahertz poses to go and
stick in a satellite they have to keep
their own lines of you know purses going
to keep that stuff going so we strap our
satellites to Moore's law and and then
we've really also do another thing
that's quite equally important I think
to keep our satellites agile we keep on
uploading new code again pretty obvious
to computer programmers down here on
terra firma but in the aerospace sector
there was always hesitation because you
could put up new code and it can send
this out light into a spin and there
goes a billion dollars right so people
are scared about doing that and NASA we
would take typically take about a year
for us to get new code uploaded to our
satellites so we just upload new sets
code to us at lights all the time we
normally we've had it got a couple going
that we are more experimental with and
if it works we just you know copy it
across the whole fleet so we take an
agile approach to our software
development as well so that's that
really so we take advil aerospace then
we had to figure out how to manufacture
them its scale and i don't mean scale
like you know iphones or whatever but
but hundreds is the sort of scale that
we need to build satellites in and and
we figured out how to do that and that
meant redesign in the saddle line for
manufacturability so that everything was
plugged together like ribbon cables
rather than us wiring it all together
and three exits milled parts rather than
5 x's milled part so that we could have
a shorter timeline to get the iterations
in and things like that so we redesigned
them to be able to build them in in
large numbers so in the aerospace sector
typically it takes the fastest people
develop a satellite is a year or so and
we can do it orders of magnitude better
than that i'm going to tell you the
specifics now then of course we had to
get rides in space in fact when we're in
our garage we put our first deposit on a
launch vehicle with our pocket money so
and but when we were getting towards the
bigger payments that wasn't going to
work and that's when we went in our
Steve Jurvetson like who I guess it
helps to sponsor this series or dfj does
to give us some more serious dollars
because in particular we needed more
serious dollars for these things rockets
are expensive it turns out and we needed
to get our satellites up so we've
actually had nine launches to date eight
of which was successful I'll tell you
about the one that wasn't in a in a bit
so we've and these were over the last
two years so we roughly had a quarterly
cadence of launches to test our
technology and keep on iterating it and
so every time we have that new
generation of satellite we put it up but
we have also been launching these fleets
of satellites so we've now launched 87
successfully into space on rockets like
this this is a falcon 9 rocket that
launched a month ago but we launched on
anyone's rockets which we will stick our
satellites in any nook and cranny that
is available and we've launched on
Russian Rockets oils Knepper we're
launching this year also on a Japanese
rocket on an Indian rocket wherever this
space will go excuse the pun so and this
is just to show you a little video this
is a this is one of the advantages of
going by the International Space Station
you can get the astronauts to take these
nice videos out the window I guess they
got nothing better to do and so so we
like seeing this is it sort of flash at
the end which is kind of fun when it
glints in the Sun I thought we could
have planned that you know here's some
of the latest ones that just came out I
put these are this is a just animated
gif of them coming out of the space
station it's just shits and giggles here
ok so then we have to get the data down
so we have a system of ground stations
around the world we've got about a dozen
of these so the inside that is a five
metre parabolic dish antenna which
points that the satellite as it goes
ahead and gets the data down and the
satellite at the same time points at the
ground station to maximize gain on the
little
antenna that we have on the front flap
that perhaps you saw the
artist-in-residence evidently got to
these guys as well as you can see he
goes around the world this one just gave
birth we got another one next to it now
we actually three ground stations in
each site roughly speaking because
there's so many satellites in the sky as
they pass across there's actually
through three or four satellites in the
sky so we need three each location
picking up the data so that's obviously
how we get the data down so then what
well then we get things like this this
is one of the first images from the
wider field of view telescope that I was
just mentioning we just launched a month
ago and so this image is about 20 x 15
kilometers in size the pixel size is
about 3 meters on the ground so we can
see objects that are about 5 meters
across you can see a canopy of it zoom
in you'll see we see a canopy of trees
you'll see just about you can see large
vehicles on roads you can't see people
and in fact we think that's a strategic
advantage we don't want to get into
privacy areas and it's quite difficult
to be able to detect a person's face
from space it turns out but we wouldn't
want to do that even if we could and so
we get images like this I'll show you a
few more this is Beijing Airport this is
some area in Tibet I guess this is when
we zoom in this is an area also in China
and you know again when we zoom in you
can just about see the vehicles on that
road there this is an area in Texas
again we can zoom in the other day I was
looking out for to see it where Elon's
building his Tesla gigafactory just see
if we got any pictures of their just
shits and giggles I'm trying to tease
him or something and we didn't be get
that his / month or so interval hidden
build this building could you see that
so I sent that to him he said it was a
lot more coming
anyway so even billionaires can't hide
from our their secret facilities from
from our steely eyes okay so what I
wanted to do is just show a few more
pictures on the web here if I can do
that do you say it's I agree so the real
key thing that matters here is change
because what there's daily imaging of
the whole planet do it means you can see
changes as they happen around the planet
and so here are two images taken 24
hours apart and and as I slide this back
and forth you can obviously see the
changes the most obvious thing being
that fire right in the top right there
but actually if you look at this field
here you can see my mouth there and this
field down here you can see that they've
been harvested or tilt or something in
that in that period every single picture
we get down when we put it on the
Earth's surface to the latest imagery
that has been taken we see changes
people have built a building people have
removed a treat people have harvested a
feel the earth is changing it's
constantly changing we think of it as
this static thing because this that's
what we've had access to static imagery
that's old when we have more higher
cadence imagery we see these changes
this is one that we showed a people that
might be interested in the more sort of
monetary aspect of this is that of
course because he changes in in in mines
in this case a gold mine in China and we
could therefore estimate the volumetric
output of these mines and of course we
can do that for every single mind around
the whole world every single day that's
useful for people betting on markets say
in this case the gold market but we can
also tell the output from every single
crop field around the world every day
like every soy field around the day
around the world every day that's useful
for the farmers of course it's also
useful for people in New York trying to
make bets on markets so there's lots of
people interested in our data from that
sort of reason we can see construction
projects obviously that is a Landsat
image on the left
and our image on the right Landsat is
that satellite I showed you earlier as a
slightly higher resolution even though
they're much much smaller satellites and
for various reasons said the drought in
California we can see these reservoir
levels again the thing to think about is
the fact that we can see this around the
whole world every day every single
reservoir we can see the levels every
day every single farmer's field we can
see the their crop yield here I've just
maybe I need to sign in don't try and
guess my password it's going to be
tricky so so yeah we can we can see
these changes so this what we do here is
this is our image and if you look at
this bridge down here and the previous
most recent image taken of this area
somewhere in Texas I don't know if it's
dallas or something again that bridge
appearing disappearing appearing
disappearing and of course we can just
put an automated mask over that defines
these changes and figures out where
things are that have changed in this
case obviously pulls out that bridge but
lots of other things that have changed
somebody painted a roof over there some
people building built some buildings
over there and we can do this around the
whole world in fact in China it's like a
bloody one giant construction site so
here maybe I should make this a bit
bigger for you guys con jeez so here
again that's the most recent other
satellite image taken of that area our
image bang bang bang bang you can see
the massive amount of construction
that's taken place there again will
loads of changes and as we zoom around
China this is just rendered on the fly
in the browser this particular there's
just more and more construction all over
the places are evidently another area
where the Chinese have built another
town overnight you know that's just what
goes on in China
and and this is so and as we zoom out
you'll just get the sense for if this is
all loading so these are now all of our
images in strips and we slowly striping
and covering the earth as we go around
and and again if I turn back on the the
change change detection you'll just
start seeing all these changes whether
it's because of agriculture whether it's
because people have done something for
that field these are these circular crop
fields you know all around all around
the world and we see these changes as
they're taking place obviously there's a
lot of utility to that for a lot of
different people and again our goal is
to put this data out there so that
people can build their own apps on top
of that and maybe this says you know you
you you you want your fire detection app
well you find red pixels and then alert
fire departments of your your of the
lat/long of that fire or if you're
somebody doing news you you find the
floods and fires and earthquakes or
whatever in Pakistan if that's your area
of interest or missing planes you know
you see these things and you could maybe
set up alerts to pull out the
information to get the information you
need for whatever you're trying to do in
the world so with that I'm just going to
talk about some of the challenges with
of building and launching satellites
here's one of them it's called Rockets
can explode this is actually an amateur
video of the one rocket that didn't work
that we have got our satellites on it's
a little bit shaky but I think it
captures some of the fascination with
this particular lon so it gets up a
little bit and then doesn't lose the
world above it's about higher
the delay in the sound you can secure
this point it's not going so well
it's gotta be loud wait a few seconds so
that's one of the challenges we face let
me to come back to the that's one of the
challenges satellite launches can that
going to come back up excellent yeah
launches can be delayed quite often and
sometimes explode like that we had 26
satellites on that particular launch
vehicle that exploded into smithereens
that day we put a lot of effort into it
I was annoying but luckily we had had
quite a few launch we'd already had four
launches that year we were doing pretty
well we'd already launched more
satellites in one year than anyone else
in history we were doing pretty well and
our strategy is put our satellites on
lots of different launch vehicles and if
one blows up it's not the end of world
that's part of the advantage of having
our satellites be smaller and put on
more regular launches is that we don't
have one big 1 billion dollar satellite
and if it explodes that really is the
end of the world so so that happens and
I just wanted to talk about some of the
challenges only because I thought it
might be useful and we obviously one of
the key risk areas we weren't sure about
as we started the company was where are
we going to be able to get the
regulatory approval to launch these
satellites and operate these satellites
in space and one thing if you're bowing
and and a building this billion-dollar
satellite and you can pay you know tens
of millions of dollars to some lawyers
in DC or whatever to lobby to get some
approvals or whatever that goes on you
know and we weren't sure as a small
start-up how we were going to be treated
and how it was going to work but luckily
the good news there is that we really
did manage to get all the licenses and
approvals we have to get three kinds of
licenses for our satellites and Noah
licenses to take images of the earth we
have to get FCC licenses and I tu
licenses
to broadcast in these particular radio
channels to ensure we don't interfere
with other satellites in terms of the RF
frequencies end and we also get to have
to get state department approval to send
the satellites abroad for launch when
we're sending them award for launch
because state department considers the
munitions well and if you think about
that rocket maybe that's true although I
we can call our satellites doves so we
didn't think of the moon it was
munitions at all we think of them as
having a peaceful mission but there we
go actually there's a fun story about
the doves that was named by one of our
engineers and he he was what he was
thinking about there was the fact that
in in aerospace there's a lot of people
in to call their satellites after birds
but normally birds of prey so he eagle
eye Kestrel swooped kill this whatever I
spy that and and we had a humanitarian
mission for us at light so we thought we
would take the piss out of the military
and call them doves it's a bit of fun
anecdote there one of the other
challenges perhaps this is the most
important one really is the
engineering systems engineering
complexity of what we've tried to
undertake and this is not a yo app turns
out there's quite some differences in
fact I find the yo app and mockery on
humanity and I think the founder of that
company does too so that's we probably
in sync there but you know we have
probably a thousand features of our
inventory and satellite a building shop
control system that is more complicated
in that yo app and probably 10,000
features of our mission control system
that schedules and deploys and manages
all the satellite operations than that
fricking yo app you know so it is a
mockery of humanity but anyway there is
a complex system engineering thing we
have the satellites all those components
that I mentioned they're going have to
all work together and have to work
together without any human interference
right directly we can't go up there and
press the reset button we're really once
they launched their launched and so we
have to have all these watchdog circuits
and all of those components have to work
together harmoniously then they said
let's have to work with each other those
satellites then all have to communicate
with your system of ground stations all
around the world then it has to be a
mission control architecture that that
schedules all those satellites to take
pictures or turn to the ground station
to coordinate all of that and all the
bespoke interfaces to all the different
ground stations and then that's just
when we get the data down to the ground
and then we have to have this fairly
sophisticated set of programs to turn
the data into something useful we had to
stitch it to the Earth's surface so this
image comes down with the metadata of
his where I was when I took the picture
in his roughly was pointing but it still
doesn't give it accurately enough so
then that sort of plus or minus a tenth
of a picture or something and then we
what we do is we scour the earth for
ground control points sharp peaks of
mountains buildings roads things like
that and then find the same thing in
each image and then rectify them
automatically to the Earth's surface and
doing that whole process color
calibration atmospheric correction ortho
rectification that means Q can't the
topography the geo rectification that's
what I was just talking about cross
calibration between all these satellites
we have this complicated data pipeline
so just the sheer complexity was really
I think the thing that was the biggest
challenge and still is the biggest
challenge for us as as an organization
and it's sort of tightly related to the
goal we took on but it is pretty hard
and I think finding the right investors
we we lucked out at many in many ways I
think but I think finding the right
investor was really key people that
really take the long haul view was
really he and you're not too
prescriptive I mean each each startup
needs its own way to go and of course
which we're disrupting a big sector and
there's a war is about how they react
this again was that end-to-end system I
just want to emphasize the complexity
there so I wanted to say a few things
about some of the other aspects of this
not related to our progress but just
that I think contextual things that
we've learned that
I thought might be interesting to share
firstly the question we often thought of
at the beginning was why hasn't anyone
done this and I think its usual to
reflect on that just because it helps
you think of what might be good other
ideas to pursue and so and we think that
there were so three major reasons one
was the technology readiness so I mean
we leveraged a lot of technology that
people have been spending billions of
dollars compressing sensor systems into
these devices and we leverage a lot of
that we don't have phones in our
satellites although we did when we were
at NASA put some phones in space that's
another story we we leveraged a lot of
the sensor systems that the
accelerometers the rate gyro is the
magnetometers all of that stuff that's
been stuffed into the little GPS since
it's the little and and low-power
processing ARM chips and so forth so we
leveraged a lot of that and simply it
wouldn't have been possible to do a lot
of that technology that stuffed into
that little box five or ten years ago so
that technology maturity was one part
that also applies on the cloud compute
aspect of this all the processing of the
imagery you know ten years ago we'd have
had to stand up our huge own server
system to deal with all of the imagery
but now we don't we can just sign up on
on Amazon Web Services and the other
thing was the stage in our career so for
our particular problem of the systems
engineering complexity that I just
mentioned it was very useful that we'd
spent a number of years at NASA learning
how to build satellites and learning how
to get launches and the regulatory staff
and operations and duh but we weren't
too far along such that we had bought
into all of it and and and so we
questioned a lot of it when we left in
fact we tore up most of the what's
called the NASA gold rules for satellite
manufacturing you know we don't use
clean rooms we don't use a lot of the
processes that NASA use uses because we
think it was relevant but we did know
enough about them to be able to apply
the ones that were needed and so it
leased for our particular project that
stage in our careers was kind of about
right which is about 30 years old FYI
and then there was a need for this this
product I think that was genuine need
for for what we were delivering at this
time I think everyone has a cute
awareness of our need to become better
at sistering this this planet in a
sustainable way and and so there was a
strong need when we went out to the
marketplace so Tina has to be detached
on the my entrepreneurial story there
isn't really much of one but it could be
somewhere as roughly like this physics
planetary science planet so I study
physics their masters in physics and
space science technology at Leicester
University and did a PhD in quantum
physics actually at Oxford and then
finishing up that stuff at UCSB which is
how I ended up in the States and then I
ended up working at NASA for six years
of various planetary missions lunar
missions and astrophysics missions sent
a couple of probes the moon one that was
looking for water we slammed a small
probe into the South Pole of the moon
moon and I was on the science team for
that mission and we we did in fact fine
lots of water on the moon which is kind
of cool and because people thought it
was dry it turns out there's a boatload
of water and that's pretty cool for
ultimate human exploration because the
moon is the obvious place to settle but
having extra volatiles there like water
and co2 and methane the other things we
found is very useful for for putting up
a self-sustainable settlement there it
makes it much easier and but honestly we
wanted to have more practical
applications that's very nice for
science and long term settlement and
backing up the species if you like but
we want to have more practical
applications so we wanted to turn our
attention to something a little bit more
focused on the earth and as I mentioned
the founders of the company we all met
at the UM so as a little bit violent
career we did put these phones into
space when we turn to leave NASA NASA
was very supportive of that we we hired
back some of the people that were into
positions that we were going to vacate
and left and there was very supportive
because it's kind of part of NASA's
mandate to spin out technology so in
this case that was relatively easy bit
like leaving Stanford I'm sure you
supported in that sort of thing
so there's not much really much to say
about my entrepreneurial journey so to
speak but let me like but I have
sketched a few pieces of advice that I
thought maybe lickable if you guys want
to go into into doing something
entrepreneurial yourselves the first
thing is to do something meaningful to
help the world I know everyone says that
some level but I really really mean it
like it's so pointless just going out
there to make cash or some other thing
and so many people have ideas but you've
already got to think about whether or
not it's a really good idea and and
something that's going to be
differentiating over what everyone else
is doing and I really encourage you to
wait until you have a very compelling
idea don't just do an idea as soon as
you have an idea like wait until it is
one that you think is not a question of
whether I might want to do this I have
to do this the timing is right that
everything is right unless that is in
your mind if you think is probably
pretty good it's probably pretty fun
that's not the idea I think you should
go away take a year off travel around
the world get some inspiration do
something else don't start us up because
once you start startup you in there for
five years ten years who knows and and
you don't want to wake up five or ten
years later and found you're doing
something completely pointless like a yo
app and so like do something meaningful
to help the world like don't don't at
all budge on that constraint is my
advice I've got some other things don't
do an MBA I don't see any advantage to
that in physics some of the best
physicists studied mathematics and my
old supervisor Oxford the study of
mathematics and a lot of the best
physics people had study mathematics are
the best philosophers I study philosophy
law a lot of best philosophers didn't
study philosophy their study history or
they studied neuroscience or they
studied something but they didn't study
philosophy and I think the same is true
in business the best business people
didn't study business they were
entrepreneurs in some other technical
discipline and then they apply
themselves and you can and should bring
in the business experience that you need
but that that's not what you need to get
a company going
you need a great idea and that's not
related to business skills yeah I think
laterally I think there's a lot of
kool-aid around Stanford in particular
around go to do a start-up you know like
that's the solution to any problem that
you might come up with you know I need
some popcorn gonna start okay right well
there's lots of other mechanisms you
know and i think it's worth thinking
laterally about what one is appropriate
if it really is a company is it a B Corp
or a c-corp is it a flexible purpose
corporation what and if it's not you
know is it a non-profit is it academia
where if you have an idea where is the
best an optimal place to affect that
problem not just default to a start-up
so highest people smarter than
yourselves that's that's that's that's
really good advice that I was given do
something you love that's sort of
relates the number one I think and get
ready for a wipeout and I like and doing
a start-up to having children not live
had any but it seems like that like the
first few years is a wipeout and that
seemed like everyone's experienced
having kids and have humility what I
mean by that is I think it's good to
wait until you've done something before
announcing it that don't say I'm gonna
do this this and this and it's going to
change the world how about instead do it
and then show people what how it's
useful and then they'll appreciate it so
much more I think so don't set yourself
up for failure oh that's the other
reason not to do that but but I think
generally having humility is your thing
so I I have a slide and which relates to
raising money I don't know if any of you
guys are interested in raising money but
I call it the 12 days of raising don't
many because everyone always asked me to
about raising money so I just put it up
here I said but but it was rather i only
talk to the people that are making the
decisions talk that is the partners in
venture firms no point talking to anyone
else just don't even take the meeting if
it's not their partners that
make this isn't get the right amount of
money change the direction just quickly
if if you're raised amount is wrong
change direction you've got to be
adaptable test it with someone that's
kind of obvious to dry run be different
don't turn up with a slide deck totally
boring do something else whatever it is
go for a hike with them we just turn up
and put a satellite on their desk and
then discussed it and that was it and we
thought that turned out to be very
compelling I mean it not every style
maybe has satellites and that's that's
kind of fun but but then there must be
something else you can do other than
just doing a normal slide deck avoid the
details be dynamic adaptive what their
interests are if you're talking a
billionaires they you know find out what
they're interested in in real time and
then adapt it are you interested in
climate change are so let's can help
with that you know use to people don't
go what on their own it looks weak use
deadlines random deadlines the work it's
so surprising you're like literally one
of our founders said to one of the
investors I'm going on holiday on
Tuesday sorry we we've got to have a
term sheet by them and they bought it
and they just gave us a 70 by then over
like that was totally random but you
just have to issue these things people
work to deadlines so you just have to
issue deadlines not quite you know I'm
doing my hair but like you know set a
bit not far yeah you've got to do it
fast you gotta from the moment you first
meet this person the probability of the
transaction having goes down ten percent
a day like you've got to seal it within
days either it works like that or not at
all you're going to be confident and
you've got to turn the tables a little
bit you've got to say what what are you
guys going to do for us and that
immediately puts them in a different
reference frame which is starting thing
oh well then why we can help you connect
with people and we can help you and that
puts them in the psychological mindset
of they're already in and you don't ever
talk to the investors about other
investors you're speaking to because
they will talk to each other okay so I
wanted to end by coming back to this um
ah beautiful spaceship earth that's what
but Mr Fuller called this and it's funny
sometimes you you need to go up to
understand what's going down and what I
mean by going down great what's going
down on the planet it kind of took us
getting off the planet to realize that
we are on a spacecraft they took us
putting spacecraft outside the
atmosphere to realize that we're already
on a spacecraft and it's called the
earth and its orbiting the Sun you know
40 kilometers a second or so and and
that spacecraft just like any spacecraft
you have to take care of it if you're in
a spacecraft in orbit around the Earth
you have to take care of the co2
otherwise if it gets away you're
you need to take care of your food
systems you've got to take care of your
closed-loop life-support systems well
recently I mean like 1970 recently on
geological time scales at least or
evolutionary timescales we realized that
we are on a spaceship ourselves it's
called the earth and we've all got to
take care of it and this is where I
think that we fit in now which is really
just by second the last layer which is I
think there's a set now of global
sensing companies that are standard
drivers and that's what I'm I think of
ourselves as a company that that helps
out the sensor systems around the whole
earth so that we can take data of it
regularly enough to do something about
it and it mostly you guys are engineers
and you probably know that in order to
effect a system you have to take data
about it on faster than the timescale of
change of that system right so if you're
tumbling you need to take taser on how
you're tumbling on faster than the time
scale of the tumbling kind of obvious
well with our spaceship earth we're not
taking data on a fast enough time scale
of all the things that we're affecting
the planet with and so if you take
imagery it so you once a year of the
planet but deforestation is happening on
days and weeks that's not very useful by
trying to get this data that happens on
a daily basis we hope to get inside that
decision-making lip such that we can
help us to steer and steward the planet
better but I think will be one of many
companies doing that kind of thing so I
put us in that sort of respect
and I also post in the sector the last
point as a you know but this is the
macroscopic challenge of our times
sustainable it up keep of our
environment and you know we've already
wiped out a massive fraction of the
species on this planet that's why it's
called the six major extinction event
that we've done in the last sort of
hundred years and we need to do
something about that and this is the
microscopic challenge of our time and I
I really hope that we as a company fit
into that by helping us to get us the
data that we need and just to give a
very concrete example in the pool we
actually donated all of our imagery of
the poor to the efforts that were going
on over there and that's and and
actually just a couple of days ago we
heard back that we had found to
basically there was crowdsource campaign
to look through imagery and find where
problems that having weird mudslides had
gone on and so forth and there were two
villages that were found or towns that
have found that that weren't on the maps
of all the aid agencies are now are
getting relief effort because of our
data and that's just one example but
that's something that I think it's nice
and really the whole reason why we
started the company in case you guys
have any interest in working apparent we
do have lots of jobs so and just to tell
you just a tiny bit about ourselves very
open collaborative culture about 150
people from top universities Stanford
does currently have the most we just
checked I just checked for this tour but
MIT is very close so we warned that you
might be being beaten out by MIT soon
anyway so we we we have a lot of talks
like today Phil Rosedale who studies
second life came around last week Al
Gore came around and talked to us we
have an interesting speakers come by and
tell us about what they're interested in
and how it relates to our data and so
forth and we do cool projects like that
Nepal thing was just a few people
getting together ok what can we do to
help the situation in a pool we must be
able to do something and and did so if
you have any interest in joining us we
do have internships this summer and in
Jenner
and permanent jobs and just email people
at planet com if you're interested in a
job with that I'll open it up for any
questions that's great so we've got time
for five minutes panting yes in the
islands I think it's really cool how you
kind of got away from the large-scale
like be expensive satellites you're kind
of getting that rapid prototyping
iteration going yeah but it seems like
that would have ramifications for like
the lifetime and satellites as well but
maybe you could replace this lot faster
so what you see is like the lighting
especially with electronics I mean
Moore's law you mentioned that yeah this
is something that you can get keep
getting better great question so
essentially what happens to the lifetime
of the satellite is we take this rapid
approach so we put our satellites in
most of us are like lifetime is dictated
by orbit altitude and depending on the
orbit altitude they last sort of one to
three years um and we are optimal orbit
is around three years because actually
by that point Moore's law has gone on
and and the satellites become obsolete
and other than that we want to keep them
as low as possible to get a good
resolution per unit you know satellite
so so so that would be our aim and and
so that's different from the sort of
traditional model of trying to get your
satellite lasting 10 or 20 years and
next wishin yeah in the back sorry I
hate to say this out loud but I worked
at iridium years ago oh yeah yeah and
it's so refreshing to see what you guys
are doing his face but what about all
these other new technology other than
other than just two satellites the blues
with Google the drones with facebook it
would be nice to see or more different
technologies come out other than just
that because the Blues are really really
huge but your eyes are really really
small and it's just I'm so excited for
you you having so much fun thank you and
what what was the question I think I
question is what other technologies are
you guys gonna shout other than just the
satellite got it well the satellites is
quite enough for now um it turns out but
surely I think we would love to
collaborate with people doing drones and
and other sorts of satellite systems to
integrate the data sets and i think that
there's a lot of utility in merging
these data sets from different I mean
obviously drones can do much higher
resolution imagery for example but much
much smaller area and you know
agriculture is twenty-six percent of the
world's land area you can't very well
cover that with drones you need
ridiculous number of them right but if
you have a building site and there's
something's change you might want to
send a drone in to see it because you
want to know bit by bit how many bricks
of change you know so so it depends on
your use case but I think they can be
very complimentary and they should be
sort of on the same sort of place yes
how do you think that at some point for
ocular reactively the military knocks at
your door huh can you comment at all on
the dialogue of that yeah pluses and
minuses listen hey I can the complete
answer is no no as yeah of course some I
branch of the government military and
intelligence communities are very
interested in our data and from lots of
different countries and and the way we
talk to those guys is they can have our
data the same as anyone else on the same
sort of tons and that's that's but but
yes you know a lot of those guys have
approached us but you know our main aim
is that is to serve the humanitarian and
commercial side but we do want to be
equal yeah you know give our data to
everyone that comes to ask no they have
not tried to restrict the data no no not
per se yes over that multiply on the
question earlier now if miniaturization
continues like you've done nah what
other applications could you imagine for
mentor I space satellites oh well so we
could we could go into communication
satellites we could do GPS satellites we
could do radar satellites there's lots
of different things and I think we might
be interested in doing that in the long
haul but right now we're sort of laser
focused on this earth imaging mission
yes but this is so very great a mission
of doing
to the planet but have you ever thought
about like your data can be used by
terrorists kind of compromise me yes oh
sorry I forget to repeat the question
the question was a kid I've data be used
in a bad way for example by terrorists
and absolutely we thought a great deal
about this we started this company from
a do good position and and as with any
technology there's good and bad uses of
it and the vast majority of the use
cases of our imagery are positive in my
opinion having thought through the long
list that I could come up with and if
that were not the case I wouldn't be
pursuing the technology at all I think
it's really important that we all take
responsibility for deciding what
technologies to focus on based on the
use and and whether it's really a net
positive however yes there are bad uses
of a satellite imagery that I'm sure
will come come about and all I can say
is that we will do our best to try and
restrict those negative uses as best we
can other questions yes over the fact
that you can't right now see people but
you also said that more laws yes relate
to yes or like I can clearly see that in
10 years you guys are will be seeing
who's going bald before they know it
actually probably not let me give you a
bit of a reason why I mean fundamentally
our resolutions dictated by the optic
science and even the largest satellites
that ever gets launched there is a bus
science satellites crossing villains
ours like the one you saw the limit of
the size of the optic is limited by the
size of the rocket that's carrying them
and that's normally for 25 meters wide
and even if you take that you can only
get down to sort of 10 centimeter
resolution to 10 sending me to pixels
well with 10 centimeters pixels you
can't see someone so even with those
biggest satellites you can't really see
or identified people that doesn't mean
you can't do some things like track
vehicles right so that it's not like
there's zero implications for privacy
but i think is extraordinarily difficult
to get to that so
the level that would be necessary to to
actually identify people yes space
debris yeah and i was wondering after
the lifecycle of these from one to three
years genu the thought of a way to break
that factor there today yeah absolutely
so what I thought after contributing
just getting rid of space debris I would
contribute some more space debris so
that was why we began the company no
yeah so what happens is that space
debris is a real problem and there's
about 30 million pieces of open space
debris orbiting the Earth today man-made
debris and of which most of which we
can't track even it's too small to track
so it's a real problem and in particular
above about 800 kilometers between eight
and twelve hundred kilometers where the
main density is where most people to put
their satellites over here some of
history's it's got so dense that now
there's a runaway cascade where the
collisions between debris and satellites
and debris and debris are creating more
debris because every time they collide
they create lots of little bit then the
debris is coming down such that we're in
a runaway cascade in that thing it's
called the Kessler syndrome and we keep
our satellite way below that like four
to five hundred kilometers where there's
enough atmospheric drag that you just
pulls the satellites down so the or the
simple answer is that they just come
down really quickly and they can't
possibly contribute to this long-term
challenge but we would love eventually
to to try and mitigate that problem
that's up high altitude because if we
don't we'll have a serious dilemma on
our hands about utilizing space in the
long haul and bit like climate change
the sooner you nip it in the bud the
better and so when I wasn't as I was
working on schemes to try and do the
dipping in the bud if you like you mean
our side lights yeah and well they decay
in a fairly predictable way based on the
altitude and it sort of the the
atmospheric has an exponential density
with altitude and and so we're depending
on the altitude we put them out we know
pretty well how long they can last it
also depends of course which way we're
pointed
you